bonjour tout le monde aujourd'hui je
vais parler en français avec you un
texan qui a une chaîne un programme qui
aide les gens qui apprennent le français
et ça s'appelle le français authentiques
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer qu'est
ce que c'est
le français authentiques et comment tu
as décidé de faire crise ce genre de
services pour les gens qui apprennent le
français bien sûr
bonjour steve merci bonjour à tous je
suis très content d'être d'être ici de
discuter avec toi puisque comme je vais
l'expliquer tu fais partie de mon
histoire et de l'histoire de france est
authentique donc je m'appelle johan
tekfak j'ai 36 ans je vis dans le
nord-est de la france à metz
à peu près entre paris et strasbourg
j'ai deux enfants six et huit ans et
j'ai créé en 2011 le site français
authentiques que tu as a man se est
mentionné alors c'est venu en fait par
le biais de deux choses
ce site la première chose c'est que en
j'étais en autriche le travail en
autriche et j'ai eu mon premier job là
bas je suis ingénieur de formation j'ai
eu mon premier job en autriche avec ma
femme est on arrivé dans un pays dans
lequel on ne parlait pas la langue
donc moi je l'avais étudier un peu à
l'école ma femme pas du tout et on a
donc bien sûr dû apprendre l'allemand
et on l'a fait sur place je me suis
aperçu parce que quand je suis arrivé en
autriche
j'ai pris beaucoup de cours et je me
suis aperçu que ont continué d'enseigner
beaucoup de théories beaucoup de
grammaire conjugaison listes de
vocabulaire à des gens qui finalement
n'en avait plus besoin
je voyais bien que ce qu'on enseigne est
en cours
c'était bien pour atteindre un certain
niveau mais j'avais un niveau qui était
suffisant pour bien passer à autre chose
donc en cherchant je suis tombé sur des
gens
dont cette personne qui peut qui a
partagé pour d'expérience sur
l'apprentissage des langues
je me suis un peu inspiré de stéphane
cros nationaux si c'était un peu mes
deux inspirations toit avec une
inspiration à ces pratiques et stéphane
klein plus un peu plus de théorique qui
expliquer de façon un peu plus de
théorique ce qu'ils pensaient de
l'apprentissage des langues comme j'ai
découvert ça je me suis dit on peut
apprendre des langues autrement en
parallèle de ça j'étais donc en autriche
et je rencontrais beaucoup de non
francophones qui comprenait bien le
français avait quelques difficultés à
s'exprimer et me disaient aller en cours
il allait encore en cours ça faisait 10
12 15 ans qu'ils étudiaient le français
il avait en cours à l'alliance française
et c'est alors en soit il n'y a rien
contre allée à la d'une science
française mais je me suis dit pourquoi
ne pas appliquer ses méthodes dont on
n'entendait pas parler en 2011 à
l'apprentissage du français et en
faisant quelques recherches sur internet
j'ai vu que tous les sites qui
enseignait le français le faisait en
traduisant de l'anglais il n'y avait pas
de site en france est authentique
c'est comme ça que j'ai créé français
authentiques donc désolé pour la longue
introduction mais c'est comme ça qu'on a
que tout a commencé
et d'après ce que j'ai vu
le site présente donc des discussions
des monologues peut-être des fois des
dialogues des discussions mais surtout
même des monologues mais c'était une
scène française naturel dépensé sur de
différents thèmes et forcément
d'après mon expérience quand on part
naturellement c'est à dire on n'écrit
pas d'abord produits enregistrés on part
d'abord pour ainsi créer une
transcription d'une discussion naturel
ce genre de contenu et est très simple
l'important c'est très intéressant c'est
souvent plus facile point de vue de un
village du niveau de vocabulaire qui est
utilisé donc ça répond à un besoin réel
qui existe dans non seulement dans le
passé mais dans beaucoup de langues
donc je te salue cette initiative est
sûre qu'elle a été
réactions et comment tu as pu donc
développé ce site est pour atteindre
parce que maintenant tu as une audience
quand même assez répandue oui oui j'ai
une audience assez répandue et bien il
ya en fait la réponse elle a été un
petit peu à la mesure des progrès qu'on
fait dans une langue
pourquoi j'ai une audience il ya une
audience très importante qui fit
français authentiques aujourd'hui bas
parce que depuis 2011 je publie chaque
semaine des vidéos chaque semaine des
podcasts
j'essaye d'aider un maximum de gens et
je participe beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc j'ai persévéré et en persévérant et
en essayant d'offrir de la valeur
eh bien on progresse essayez de la même
chose dans les langues en fait les gens
qui travaillent le plus qui persévèrent
pas forcément se dit oh je vais faire
deux heures de français par jour ou deux
heures dans une autre langue par jour
mais le faire de façon régulière vont
progresser donc c'est comme ça en fait
la réponse a été assez rapide france est
authentique a été populaire assez vite
mais l'audience a s'est créé de façon
exponentielle en fait c'est comme les
progrès j'aime j'aime comparer ça au
progrès qu'on peut avoir dans une langue
c'est vraiment avec les gens la
persistance et le travail a jamais de
magie en fait tu n'entends rien dans
rien de ce qu'on peut faire
donc j'ai des podcasts et des vidéos
heynckes escale le podcast et le guide
dans le fichier sonore du vidéo de la
vidéo ou est-ce que c'est sépare alors
je tenais de chaque lundi je
une vidéo et j'essaie de faire comme tu
as dis donc j'ai pas de 32 j'écris rien
j'ai juste une structure quelques lignes
pour essayer de garder de la cohérence
mais donc je fais une vidéo le lundi en
même temps je propose le fichier mp3
mais en parallèle de sa le mercredi je
fais un podcast
j'ai appelé ça a marché avec yoann c'est
juste je prends mon micro et je vais
marcher dans la nature parce que toi tu
as à me courir moi j'aime beaucoup
marcher je cherche en parlant d'un sujet
un peu lié au développement personnel
gestion des émotions du stress
organisation quelque chose d'assez
larges donc ça c'est uniquement podcasts
et s'est dédié et chaque dimanche soir
j'ai un autre podcast qui est une
explication d'une expression idiomatique
en français il pleut des cordes sakai a
vraiment il ya dans toutes les langues
des centaines et des centaines
d'expression un petit pic et il y a
toujours des transcrit transcription
écossais voilà voilà
et je vais laisser les liens dans la
voix de descriptions là pour tout temps
ci et qu'elles sont et est-ce qu'il ya
des explications de grammaire qui vont
avec ça à part les explications que tu
expliques les dimanches à nord-ouest et
c'est uniquement fichiers sonores et
textes c'est toujours fichiers sonores
et textes et pendant des années je me
suis même refusé à parler de grammaire
pendant plusieurs années mais on
n'arrêtait pas de me demander
et quand l'audience a grossi as tu eu au
tout début les gens qui me suivent était
quand même très très avancé il y avait
peu d'intermédiaire les gens étaient
assez avancé et plus français
authentiques est devenu populaire plus
il a été suggéré sur
les flux youtube des gens plus
l'audience est un peu élargie et on a eu
des gens qui avaient parfois un peu
besoin encore d'explication
grammaticales donc ce que je fais je ne
je ne fais rien de spécifique je fais
pas une fiche et grammaire qui
accompagne un épisode par contre de
temps en temps je fais une vidéo dans
laquelle je vais essayer d'expliquer la
grammaire mais de façon un peu quand une
fois authentique
moi je suis pas prof de français donc je
suis pas légitime pour expliquer la
grammaire comme le ferait un professeur
de façon très très technique
donc j'essaie juste de donner des
quelques astuces et j'essaye de le faire
différemment donc de temps en temps peut
voir sur ma chaîne une vidéo sur le
subjonctif le conditionnel mais j'essaye
de le faire quand même de façon un peu
pratique
oui je prends le fait de faire ses
explications en français ça veut dire
que la personne qu'ils écoutent a déjà
vu l'expérience avec le subjonctif le
conditionnel oui donc tu fais référence
en français donc c'est du contenu
intéressant pour eux parce qu'ils se
sont demandé comment ça se passe
oui ils ont eut ils ont vu ça ils ne
savent pas trop trop bien comment ça
marche
et il explique en france est mal tout ça
c'est la façon de présenter la gamme
oui c'est plus sexy populaire c'est vrai
oui et puis tu m'as dit que tu as tu as
créé une société au maroc
oui donc ça veut dire que c'est une
affaire qui te permet de gagner ta vie
oui donc comme on dit en anglais comment
tu fais pour monétiser pour commente
monétiser un bon les tees et voilà
comment parce que c'est toujours
intéressant pour l'élan qui fondent et
les choses sur internet
les enseignes des langues n'importe quoi
comment tu fais pour monétiser cette
entreprise bien sûr alors au début moi
quand j'ai commencé français
authentiques
c'était un peu un peu un hobby
j'ai développé français authentiques en
parallèle de mon travail salarié pendant
cinq ans ça fait maintenant quatre ans
que je fais ça à 100% et que donc je vis
de france est authentique et la
monétisation aller assez classique en
fait je fais énormément donc de contenus
gratuits tout ce dont on a parlé
évidemment vidéos podcasts tout ça c'est
gratuit mais j'ai aussi des cours
payants pour les gens qui veulent aller
plus loin donc je crée un nouveau cours
chaque année donc ça commence à faire
beaucoup
donc c'est que c'est comme ça que je
monétise tout simplement il ya des cours
un peu spécifique par exemple j'ai deux
courts a qui sont des cours de
discussion donc le premier je les crée
en 2015 où je me suis mis avec ma femme
devant un micro je lui ai dit bon on va
simuler des situations de la vie
courante
devant un micro donc sans script c'est
ce que tu as dit tout à l'heure c'est
très important et on s'est mis à
discuter tous les deux et on a transcrit
et on a créé un cours et donc voilà j'ai
différents cours comme ceux là qui sont
vendus pour ceux qui veulent aller un
peu plus loin un peu plus vite
j'ai aussi ce que j'ai appelé l'académie
français authentiques donc que j'ai
créée il ya quatre ans en 2000 elle a
ouvert en janvier 2016 ou là on a donc
dû contenu tous les mois exclusif pour
ceux qui sont membres est un groupe
privé facebook un groupe privé whatsapp
parce que j'essaye aussi d'utiliser un
peu les nouvelles technologies pour
aider les gens à pratiquer toi et moi on
est énormément accès vers l'input
parfois là où tu peux tu le fais tu de
d'essayer de parler un peu alors ça nous
on enregistre des messages quotidiens
sur what's app par exemple entre membres
et certains membres ensuite vont
discuter sur skype entre eux mais voilà
on peut un petit peu le modèle de
monétisation de france est authentique
pendant huit ans il y avait aucune pub
sur les vidéos là depuis un certain
temps
on a des pubs sur les vidéos qui sont
aussi un petit flux la vraie raison en
fait pour laquelle j'ai activé les pubs
c'est pour pour que youtube m'aide à
être plus visibles mais bon ça c'est
encore une autre histoire
mais voilà les différents les différents
canaux les différents flux
j'ai organisé un séminaire à marrakech
il y a deux ans un séminaire à paris il
y a trois ans donc on essaye de varier
un peu les activités et est ce que le
maroc est un marché pas où est ton
marché
quels sont les pays tiers
les grands noms de d'adhérents alors le
si on prend tous les contenus si on
prend tous les contenus gratuits de
france est authentique donc il ya quand
même sur les années je suis admis lé 2
sans contenu entre tous les podcasts
toutes les vidéos je sais que toi tu es
un grand créateur de contenu donc tu te
rends compte de ce que c'est si on prend
tout bibliothèque et normes de contenu
les deux pays qui ressorte vraiment en
terme de besoin ou en termes de qui
corresponde exactement en fait à ce que
français authentiques peut offrir
c'est le maroc et d'algérie parce que
historiquement culturellement ce sont
les pays dans lesquels est bien le
français très utilisé donc ils le
comprennent très bien mais parfois alors
c'est pas vrai pour tout le monde il ya
quelques il ya quelques règles qui les
quelques week-ends enfin quelques
explications mais en gros il y à pas mal
de gens là bas qui n'arrive pas vraiment
à bien s'exprimer en français
donc ce sont eux qui cherchent du
contenu et ce sont vraiment les deux
pays qui sont les plus représentés après
on a en a le monde entier il ya
énormément de damien énormément
d'allemands d'indiens pas trop dans
canal à deux canadiens pardon canadien
hui pas mal effectivement
mais moins que j'aurais pu le penser
parfois on a il n'y a pas plus de
canadiens et d'américains par exemple
beaucoup de brésiliens
on va dire brésil espagne allemagne
oui un petit peu chinois très très peu
parce que comme je suis visible sur
youtube et facebook
c'est pas vraiment présent là bas il ya
une communauté chinoise en fait on est
présent en france est authentique et
touche un peu tous les pays
mais ce que je te dise on ne sont
vraiment les majeures les pays majeurs
de toute façon je crois que c'est une
initiative très importante
quelque chose qu'il dont on a besoin
dans toutes les langues
au canada le gouvernement fédéral
dépense d'argent incroyable 2,7
milliards de dollars pour une période de
cinq années pour faire augmenter le
niveau de bilinguisme et hors québec et
ça n'aura pas d'effet finalement lorsque
les enseignements c'est toujours les
mêmes mais une zone de traditionnels il
est le gouvernement ferait mieux de
payer des abonnements à des services
tous les canadiens c'est autre chose est
bon c'est à espérer que d'autres
personnes et je crois qu'il y en a je
connais des personnes qui font la même
chose en espagnol autre langue pour
justement combler cette lacune
c'est ce besoin qu'on a pour des
contenus naturel intéressants souvent
qu'ils vont expliquer comme tally le
stress dans la vie voilà comment la wii
c'est ça et c'est excellent et cesser ce
genre de demandes de renseignements ou
d'apprentissage d'une langue un peu
organique qui est en train de se
développer à travers des personnes comme
toi que moi et c'est inspiré que par
exemple tu dis que tu veux apprendre
j'espère que quelqu'un va faire la même
chose pour la jupiler le personnel turc
je cherche des contenus pas trop
difficile mais intéressant en jean ou
pas il ya des problèmes parce qu'il ya
le
l'arabe c'est un jour où il apprend via
les larves d'insectes pays bas rhin
c'est plus dur
moi je pense vraiment steve que la
révolution elle a déjà commencé à jeter
expliqué que quand j'ai créé français
authentiques
lorsque j'ai fait mes recherches avant
de créer le site
il y avait pas de site qui était
uniquement en français à base de
français s'étaient tous avec une
traduction j'ai fait nulle et en anglais
une ligne en français en 2011
là on est fin 2019 des sites comme
français authentiques y en a plein
naples un tutu a déjà je t'ai vu sur sur
le sur un autre podcast en français une
autre chaîne en france et il ya plein de
monde qui arrive et c'est génial pour
deux raisons la première c'est que en
général des gens qui viennent comme ça
crée des chaînes développer des concepts
bien c'est que c'est populaire et la
deuxième chose pour laquelle c'est bien
c'est que et bien ça crée une
compétition qui permet et bien aux
créateurs de ce d'essayer de se
développer de faire mieux si j'étais
resté tout seul depuis 2011
peut-être que je serais tombé dans une
certaine zone de confort et j'aurais pas
évolué et aujourd'hui il ya plein de
monde à côté de moi et je sais très bien
que voilà si je me développe pas si
j'allais être pas l'audience encore plus
forcément on va oublier et ce sera bien
normal donc je pense que toute cette
émulation
je le vois sur g on a une page in-stat g
chaque jour je vois des learned french
weeds bob dans dans toutes les dans
toutes les différentes tu as vraiment
énormément de choses qui se créent en
français je le vois parce que ça fait
partie de ma vie quotidienne mais en
italien ça existe en allemand ça existe
et je pense que même dans les langues
qui sont peut-être encore pas assez
représentées comme l'arabe ça va venir
c'est une question de temps en règle oui
et puis surtout qu' il faut des sites
comme français authentiques qui sont que
dans la langue visé dans la langue qu'on
a fait oui parce qu'il y a tout léger
pas quoi chinois sens
0n importe quoi il ya toujours l'anglais
je ne veux pas entendre entende la lan
ce soit l'arabe le français n'importe
quoi donc c'est peut-être qu'il faut
terminer déterminer là en se disant que
voilà c'est à espérer que ça va
continuer et peut-être qu'un jour si on
avait jeté par un site où il y avait
tout toutes les tous les sites qui
offrait / l'ordre l'espagnol l'arabe le
chinois est uniquement des podcasts ou
ce n'était que dans la langue commandes
identique est invisible et on pourrait
dire la langue visé hui où la langue que
la personne va prendre vraiment la
langue cible on pourrait dire oui là
aussi blanc même si avec ça donc je te
remercie cette discussion
merci je vais laisser tous les liens là
et c'est dommage que tu n'étais pas là
il ya cinquante ans quand même 65 à
parler le français
merci merci beaucoup steve c'est un
plaisir qu'est revoir au revoir